let's play a quick game here are three
doors two with nothing behind them and
one with a million tax-free dollars go
ahead and pick one of them let's say you
chose this one here's one of the other
doors
it has nothing behind it the money could
be behind your door or the other one so
would you like to change your pick
well would you this is called the Monty
Hall problem and believe it or not
you absolutely should change your pick
now most people don't believe me so let
me explain at the start you had a
one-third chance of winning the money
three Doors one with the prize then
after picking a door I revealed one of
the others at this point you thought the
chances of winning or fifty-fifty since
there were two doors one with the prize
but hold on because I know what is
behind each door I will pick the one
that has nothing behind it as to not
give away the answer
thus I give you additional information
information that you can use to have a
two-thirds chance of winning if you
switch here are all three situations one
situation is that your initial pick has
the money in it in which case the door I
choose isn't a hint to you because both
of the two other options have nothing
behind them in this case switching is
bad and will cost you the prize however
the other two scenarios are where you
pick one of the two empty doors here you
put me in a position where I have two
door options since you've already chosen
yours and the money is behind one of
them since I will purposefully not
choose the money door to reveal you
should switch to the one that I avoided
so in one scenario you lose and two you
win this makes a 2/3 chance of winning
by switching meaning you should switch
still don't believe me